john ashraf is the ceo of neurogym and
one of the
leading mindset and behavior experts in
the world
he went from being a teen who was often
getting into trouble with the law
to writing two best-selling books being
featured in eight movies
including the blockbuster hit the secret
and building five
multi-million dollar companies and today
we're gonna learn his best advice on how
to create
habits that last
rise and shine it's espresso time
i spilled
[Music]
i wake up
hey it's evan carmichael and every
morning i bring you a shot of entspresso
to help you believe in yourself more and
start
your day with confidence so good morning
i believe in you and let's do this over
to you john aserath
when we talk about how do we create
rituals or how do we change
habits that last
the first thing is to have a different
expectation
than i'm going to change in a day or a
week or in 21 days
whenever i try to change anything
my number one rule is 100 days
or i don't even start so if i want to
let's say stop caffeine it's a 100-day
commitment
so first i make longer-term commitments
and then i design a plan to retrain my
brain
around the expectation of
following through i make pre-commitments
in advance so if i say let's say i'm
going to stop drinking coffee
yeah i say okay i'm going to stop
drinking coffee i commit to it for 100
days
and then i write out well what will you
do
in the morning when you wake up and you
want a coffee
what will you do when you're at a
restaurant with friends and everybody's
having a coffee what will you do
so you counter any of the behavior
when you know the trigger is going to
happen every habit has three parts to it
there's something that triggers the the
the emotion
there's the behavior and then there's
the neurological biological reward
so when you understand the habit part of
any ritual you understand that because
we
are conditioned a certain way we're
going to have a trigger
whether it's a flower whether it's
waking up whether it's a girl or a guy
or or children coming home it triggers
a response in the brain or reaction in
the brain
well if we change the behavior over the
course of 100 days
we'll still get the reward and if we
pre-commit
to what we're going to do when we say uh
maybe today i'll have the coffee and
tomorrow i won't
maybe today i'll have the pizza or the
dessert and i'll
catch up tomorrow well if you pre-commit
in advance
that you're not going to take that
action then that's step one step
two is when you have the trigger if you
interrupt the behavior for one or two or
three or four minutes you
interrupt the neural pattern in the
brain also
so you come up with strategies when i
feel like having a coffee or dessert or
the pizza or
the croissant okay then
here's what i'm going to do instead for
five minutes
and that way i can interrupt the pattern
if you do that
long enough you'll start to develop a
new
neural pattern you'll start to develop a
new behavior
and if you do it for at least you know
66 days
but preferably a hundred days you'll
start to develop
a new way of thinking and being and
doing
that will overshadow the other pattern
in the brain
very interesting yeah so there's there's
a there's a
a psychology behind it but there's also
the neurological processes of the brain
and what happens
is our brain doesn't like change yeah
so any time that there is change
the brain see it feels uncomfortable as
soon as it feels uncomfortable
it'll send signals to the motor cortex
of the brain it'll
send messages and we'll start to
rationalize
we'll start to tell ourselves well i
shouldn't do it because of this well
maybe today's not a good day we'll i'll
start today you know but i won't
continue until
next week or you know what i really
don't want this we start to talk to
ourselves
and when we understand what the brain
does whenever we try to change
then we can start being in control
of the brain and we can override the
automatic responses there's something
called automaticity and automaticity
states that anything that i repeat over
and over and over again over a period of
time
will go from conscious effort
deliberate conscious effort willpower or
persistence and it'll become
automatic so we just have to know how
long
that is and some things take a week some
things take
60 days some habits that people have for
20 30 40 50 years take 200 days
and so you start off with a hundred day
window and you ask yourself am i willing
to give a little bit of effort for 100
days
to remove this destructive either
thought pattern or destructive
behavioral pattern
in order for me to have something
greater and
better than what i have right now
so it's very important you you focus a
lot on what you will have or what you
who you will are who you will be in the
future
to keep your your motivation yeah if you
think about this one of the best
examples that i ever came up with is
imagine if i give you
a hollywood script right now okay
and i say to you um if you
learn this script for the next six
months
i will give you 10 million dollars to
be on stage to deliver that we're going
to film you
and if you're amazing you're gonna have
a chance to win an academy award
what will you do with the script
starting today
i start to learn you start to learn you
start to read it you start to
emotionalize it you start to practice it
you start to
you start to do everything possible
to become something that's in writing
something that came out of somebody's
head that they wrote a script for
that you don't have any idea what it is
but if you made a commitment
to becoming that person and you
rehearsed it and practiced it
every day you wouldn't get it right the
first day
or the first week for the first month
for the first month
but if you knew there was a big payday
emotionally
spiritually financially and that people
would go to the theaters and
love to watch it and they'd laugh or cry
or be sad and be happy
because you were able to take them on a
beautiful emotional rollercoaster ride
then you would become that role
yeah most people are interested
they're not committed and the difference
is when you're interested you do what's
convenient and what's easy
when you're committed you do whatever it
takes
[Music]
can you repeat it sure when you're
interested
you do what's easy and what's convenient
for you
yeah but when you're committed i'm going
to get that result
you put everything into it until you get
the result
you have to have a plan for what you're
going to do when it gets hard
when you want to quit when you know what
has made you quit in the past
and when you know that thing that made
you quit is going to show up again
what are you going to do when you have a
plan for how you're going to handle it
you'll stay committed when you don't
have a plan
you're just going to react and probably
not react in a way that will make you
proud of yourself
so this is one of the biggest hacks that
i've discovered more recently in my
career and my adulthood whatever you
want to call it
is typically on goals where
i would have a hard time following
through or it got really difficult or
scary or hard i would just push myself
more to say
europe and carmichael you do scary
difficult to hard let's go
do this and i would summon the extra
strength to have to get through whatever
i was struggling with
what i've done more recently and why i
love
having this video on is very timely is
trying to
prepare in advance for some of the
obstacles that i know are going to come
so as an example i've done this recently
this week
last week i had a really rough week i i
wasn't sleeping very well i had
some big interviews from my channel i
was nervous about them i was staying up
late and
when i when i can't sleep i get restless
legs
my legs are jumping all the time and if
i'm in bed for more than 20 minutes my
legs start to get jumpy
and i've tried magnesium and i tried
vitamin b and i've tried a whole bunch
of other things to try to make it go
away and it
it's still something that i'm struggling
with the thing that's worked out the
best
is actually stretching so i stretch out
my calves i think partly it's also
because i'm on a trampoline all day long
and i'm
getting 20 000 plus steps in or jumps in
a day
that i need to i need to stretch my
calves the other way for them
to kind of i don't know de-stress anyway
maybe torture information
but what was happening last week was i
would lie in bed
i would do my stretching before lie in
bed and then i get restless legs and so
i'd get up
and i would do some work or play some
league of legends or whatever
and uh then i would fall asleep and get
tired because i was so exhausted
and last week i had a 4 30 in the
morning day where that's when i went to
sleep
2 30 in the morning day and so i set a
new plan on the weekend to say okay
i can predict that this is gonna happen
right i can i can try to muscle my way
through like i normally would do and say
i'm evan carmichael i do difficult
things
you know just stay in bed try to muscle
your way through it
which sometimes work and sometimes
doesn't work
i said you know what i'm gonna have a
plan this time what's my plan my plan is
gonna be i'm gonna do my stretching
before i go to bed
and if i get the restless legs jump your
legs
that comes up after 20 minutes because i
haven't fallen on cpm i'm going to get
up and stretch again
and so that's what i tried and it worked
and so i got up and i stretched i was
super tired i didn't want to stretch
you know i would rather just go work or
something and hop on my trampoline and
and then two hours later come back to
bed but i stretched for a couple minutes
and i said you know i'm just going to
try it let's try this
i stretched for a couple minutes i went
back to bed and i fell asleep
like oh my god i feel amazing i didn't
stay up till 2 30 or 4 30 in the morning
this is great because i had planned for
it more effectively so
whatever goal you set for yourself it
always comes back to habits
right like what are you doing on a
consistent basis and habits invariably
will get hard
there will be moments where the habit is
really difficult to keep
when you're feeling bold and motivated
and confident and you had tons of sleep
and
everything's going right it's usually
pretty easy to stay consistent on the
habits
but when obstacles come in your way it's
going to be harder and so
you know the things that will trigger
you to want to quit
right so for me it was getting jumpy
legs after 20 minutes and being in bed
when you can figure out your trigger
the thing that in the past has made you
quit why you've gone kind of
stop and start and stop and start and
stop and start what were the triggers
that made you stop
what happened and then when you're
feeling bold motivated confident have
enough rest all of that energy
maybe that's today to plan for the day
is when you're not going to have as much
will you know that this roadblock's
going to come up again
when you know that this person is going
to call you and it's going to send you
down some spiral
right this triggers is going to make you
stop the trigger that is going to make
you stop
what is your reaction going to be and
plan for that
makes a huge huge difference and allows
you to stay committed to your goals
okay so how do you do it i have a
three-step process i'm going to walk you
through but before that here's a quick
message from john assaraf
hey this john asref and do you love good
books i love to read because there's so
much wisdom
in books you get to take somebody else's
knowledge
skills research pay 15 20 bucks
and you learn so much now i'm reading
this
awesome book called built to serve find
your purpose and become the leader you
were born to be
and one of my new friends really smart
guy
really great guy who serves a lot of
people evan carmichael
wrote it and um i'm going to read a
little bit from
chapter number one and um
i love this piece and maybe it's because
i just watched
uh the series on tv on michael jordan
the last dance which is really great by
the way also but
one of the things he says here is
everybody has
michael jordan talent at something
everybody has a michael jordan talent at
something
you just haven't found it yet or you
have and you don't
believe in yourself enough to go
all in to go all in right
and you're a genius i believe you're a
genius and so does he
you're amazing you are not meant to live
a photocopy
of someone else's life you are not
created to wake up and do work that is
below your capabilities
you have michael jordan level talent at
something
and you need to uncover exactly what
your purpose is
and how you can serve and use the serve
so lots of pearls and gems and
motivational pieces
pickup built to serve evan carmichael
rising star okay so how do we plan to
stay consistent on our goals
three steps let's go step number one is
understand what is the habit that you're
having a hard time staying consistent on
there are some habits that i can do that
might be really difficult for you but
easy for me
and vice versa super easy for you but
difficult for me what i care about is
what is a habit that actually means
something to you
that you're having a difficult time
staying consistent on whether it's
something health related exercise diet
whether it's business
making videos creating content following
up with people staying
ahead of your schedule being on time
like everybody's got their own issues
for you what's the most important habit
that you want to stay consistent on
that you've historically had a hard time
doing write that down
step number two is what are the triggers
that are preventing you from staying
consistent on that habit
so if your habit is you want to eat
healthy
and you've dieted and stopped and eat
healthy for three days and then stopped
like
what are the triggers that prevent you
from staying consistent what are the
triggers that make you want to stop
so if it's eating healthy maybe it's
that you
don't have a good night's sleep and so
that makes you want to eat all sorts of
crazy food
uh it could be that you're going to an
office party
or you're hanging out with your
colleagues and all they're doing is
eating junk food and that makes you want
to eat the junk food like what are the
triggers
that are coming up that you know every
time this happens you fall off the track
and this time again and you fall off the
track
right a one-off i'm not so concerned
about but you've already
been trying to keep on this habit and
you know that you haven't stayed
consistent
and the things that are causing you to
not be consistent
are happening constantly they're
repeated patterns
so what are the most repeated patterns
for you that help you fall off track
and then step number three is understand
well what will you do right now when
that trigger comes up
when you don't sleep well what will you
do to make sure that you don't go
cheat on your diet when you do have to
go out with your friends what are you
going to do to make sure that you don't
eat all the nachos or whatever they're
eating that makes you want to eat it
right when you identify what those
triggers are while you're feeling bold
and confident
and amazing and full of potential create
the plan
to say okay when this happens i'm gonna
do this so that i don't end up down here
because too often when this happens we
just slide all the way down
we're putting the gap right we're
putting we're putting the stop the slide
stops here
it doesn't stop way down here when this
happens what are we gonna do
put that into place for yourself and
watch your life change
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day
i wanna know what was your single
biggest takeaway
from this video and write down in the
comments below
what you're gonna do about it this week
when you schedule in
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action
you have a 91 chance of following
through
versus just a 35 chance if you got
motivated but then never actually had a
plan and when you share your plan
publicly and have some accountability
your chances of following through go up
even higher so in the comments below
write down your single biggest takeaway
and your plan of action this week
so i can celebrate you this is one of
the most common uh
i guess criticisms or complaints that
people ask me about with habits is like
well you know i don't want to be robotic
right like what about like spontaneity
what about the you know freedom and
doing what i want you know i don't want
to like pigeonhole myself in this
lifestyle
but uh it's this false dichotomy because
habits don't restrict freedom they
create it you know it's often the people
who have the worst habits that have the
least amount of freedom it's the people
who
have terrible financial habits that are
always wondering like where the next
dollar will come from or it's the people
who have
poor learning habits that are always one
like feeling like they're behind the
curve
um or people who have poor fitness
habits that are always struggling to
find energy
but on the other hand if you have your
habits dialed in
if you like you know have your your
fitness habits figured out if you've got
your finances handled
then you actually have way more freedom
than you did before now you actually
have the space
to you have the energy to do what you
want you have the strength to do what
you want you have the financial ability
to spend time in areas that you want
and all of that comes from getting your
habits handled so it's
it's uh it is a little counterintuitive
this idea that like discipline equals
freedom or habits do not restrict
freedom they create it but it's
it's true that if you can handle that
stuff if the fundamentals of life are
dialed in
then you've got space for spontaneity
and creativity and freedom and all the
other stuff
if you want more inspiration morning
videos they're not on this channel
anymore i have a dedicated channel just
for it
it's right there next to me go click it
there continue to believe
and i'll see you there